[Aplausos]
pues quisiera empezar esta plática con
ustedes con esta moneda es una moneda de
10 pesos como dirían en estadística es
una moneda que no esté que no está
cargada en ningún lado y si nosotros
utilizáramos esta moneda para definir el
futuro de cada niño que nace en este
país tendríamos dos grandes opciones
águila o sol
y si dijéramos que fuera aguilar el
futuro de un niño y la lanzáramos y
cayera en águila pues buenas noticias
para este niño porque este niño nacería
en una situación
como da por decirlo de alguna manera
pero si naciera solo al momento que este
niño abriera los ojos se vería algo como
esto
abriría los ojos en la pobreza
este año en méxico van a nacer
aproximadamente 2.6 millones de niños
de los cuales 1.3 millones van a nacer
en la pobreza
pero lo que es peor de esos niños que
van a nacer en la pobreza
aproximadamente unos 600.000 van a morir
en la pobreza
y esto nos hace reflexionar de uno de
los problemas más importantes que
tenemos en este país y en lo personal
debo de confesarles que la pobreza es
algo que cambió y definió mi vida hace
aproximadamente más o menos unos 25 años
como a su momento comentaban pues yo soy
de ixmiquilpan un municipio que está en
el corazón del valle del mezquital una
de las
zonas que históricamente ha sido de las
más pobres en el país en donde el nivel
de educación en esos años hace 25 años
pues era aproximadamente nada más de la
primaria y el 50% de la población era
indígena mi familia incluido yo
formábamos claramente parte de esta
estadística promedio
cuando iba en la secundaria por eso
hablo de hace 25 años
pues estudian la secundaria del pueblo
una secundaria técnica en donde tenía un
enfoque muy práctico las secundarias
técnicas lo que buscan es preparar a la
gente para que acabando la secundaria
tenga las habilidades suficientes para
irse a trabajar y entonces en 3º de
secundaria uno de mis profesores deciden
dejarnos un trabajo para darse una idea
más o menos qué es lo que nos gustaba
hacer entonces nos dijo hagan un trabajo
de lo que ustedes quieran lo que me
interesa es que disfruten ese trabajo
entonces yo decido hacer mi trabajo
sobre física y matemáticas siempre he
sido muy nerd académicamente responsable
y entonces pues acabó mi trabajo una
semana antes y mi trabajo era más o
menos calcular la distancia más corta
que avienta en la tierra y el sol y pues
como ya había acabado mi trabajo pues ya
no más me lo dedicaba chacotear y como
ustedes pueden ver aquí esto es ex
miguel para la secundaria estaba
prácticamente en el lado opuesto de lo
que era mi casa entonces para llegar a
mi casa tenía que recorrer toda esa
línea roja y pasar por unos arcos que
vemos en la parte inferior izquierda
viendo la imagen de frente y en esos
arcos que vemos aquí era uno de los
puntos en donde se vendían y se
compraban cosas y dentro de esas cosas
pues hace 25 años cuando no habría
tratado de libre comercio había unos
puestos como estos que eran los puestos
de fayuca en donde veíamos los relojes
las plumas y una cantidad de cosas
asociadas con la modernidad que no
podíamos ver en
otro lado entonces como niño llegabas
veías los relojes fantaseaba yo en tener
uno obviamente no tenía dinero para
comprarlo
y también había una cosa como esto para
nuestros amigos millennials iguales no
lo conocen se llama grabadora y en esa
grabadora uno ponía unas cosas que
quizás tampoco conocen que no son
mp3/mp4 se llamaban cassettes y esos
casetes la gente que tenía estos puestos
pues grababa música de manera ilegal
eran cassettes piratas y esos casetes
piratas los ponían una y otra y otra vez
en estas grabadoras hasta que se
cansaban y de repente cuando ya se
cansaba no no querían rayar la cinta la
quitaban ponen el radio
y entonces
y tuve la suerte o quizás la mala suerte
de mientras estaba lloviendo el puesto
de la fayuca
había un mensaje del entonces presidente
de la republica haciendo un llamado a
toda la nación era un mensaje para que
todos los mexicanos nos uniéramos y
pusiéramos de nuestra parte para sacar
el país adelante porque vivíamos una
crisis muy importante
una de tantas
había que ya hacer un llamado a la
austeridad
nada de lo hayan escuchado actualmente
y sobre todo hay algo que menciona el
presidente entonces es todos los
mexicanos tenemos que poner un agua y
los mexicanos tenemos que
apretarnos el cinturón
[Música]
y hasta ahí quedó la verdad
me vale un cacahuate el presidente acabe
de ver las cosas seguí caminando
en lo que estaba yo
camino a mi casa de repente me llega a
la cabeza un razonamiento que era a ver
a ver a ver si escuché bien lo que dijo
el presidente es que tenemos que
apretarnos el cinturón
pero en mi lógica y conociendo el
contexto de mis tíos de mis papás de mi
familia de donde nos íbamos a apretar
más el cinturón
[Música]
en un contexto en donde la mayor parte
de la población es indígena no tiene
educación tenemos hasta sexto de
primaria esto es lo que se ve en las
comunidades pregúntele esta señora de
dónde se va a apretar el cinturón
y entonces voy rápido a mi casa llegó
corriendo a mi casa entonces luego
decido irme a la biblioteca y entonces
en la biblioteca
me siento y empiezo a pensar esas cosas
que yo había vivido en la primaria
a lo largo de mi vida en donde pues mis
tíos y mis papás se tenían que levantar
todos los días a las 2 30 de la mañana
para llegar a la orilla de la carretera
y tomar un camión como este en donde los
tenía que llevar a la ciudad de méxico
para trabajar en una obra o para
trabajar en una fábrica a las 8 de la
mañana y después de una jornada larga
que terminaba por ahí de las 6 7 de la
tarde tenían que tomar el transporte
público transporte público asignado
porque se tenían que ir a dormir o a
dormitar en un lugar como este porque no
se iban a dormir a un hotel no se iban a
ir a dormir en el lugar en donde
trabajaban porque tenían que estirar la
liga para que los pocos pesitos que
ganaban les alcanzara para regresar a su
casa
y así se tenían que ir a descansar 910
de la noche se levantaban al día
siguiente a las 5 de la mañana para el
día siguiente estar a las 8 de la mañana
de nuevo en la rutina que duraba hasta
el viernes y después el sábado el sábado
se acababa la semana y uno decía guau a
las 2 de la tarde se acaba la jornada no
a las 6 y entonces había que tomar de
nuevo el transporte público y llegar a
algo como esto la terminal de camiones
de la ciudad de mexico la terminal del
norte en donde se llenaba todo y se
sigue llenando los sábados para tomar un
camión y llegar de nuevo a hidalgo y una
vez que estábamos en 'hidalgo' cinco o
seis de la tarde uno diría ay a
descansar pues no más las noticias
porque había que llegar a sacar los
animales a trabajar la tierra a hacer
cosas del lugar inmediatamente convivir
con la familia para dormir y al día
siguiente
a despertar y uno diría bueno pues esto
ninguno se levanta tarde y pues tarde en
esos estándares es levantarte entre 6 y
7 de la mañana porque te tienes que
despertar porque tienes que hacer faena
en la comunidad y en el mejor de los
escenarios tienes chance de echarte una
cascarita un fútbol llanero y después de
ese fútbol llanero te echas unas
cervecitas y a veces acaba eso en
borrachera y al final se iba todo el
mundo a descansar por ahí de las 6 7 de
la tarde
a ver la televisión porque al día
siguiente había que levantarse a las 2
30 de la mañana iniciar de nuevo la
rutina de trabajo
repito
a qué se refería el presidente con
apretarse el cinturón
que les cortas
los haces dormir menos
no sabes trabajar más
y les quitas el fútbol les quitas las
cervezas o las bajas el salario no
el chiste es apretar
y es entonces cuando decido irme a la
biblioteca del pueblo
para buscar una respuesta a una pregunta
muy lógica quizás lo que teníamos que
preguntarnos era porque éramos pobres y
esta pregunta me decía desde un punto de
vista personal porque siendo niño en
este contexto que les comentaba de mi
familia de mis tíos pues también me tocó
trabajar en la obra me tocó trabajar 12
horas esté sembrando cosechando y te das
cuenta que por mucho que trabajes no
necesariamente te va bien en la vida
entonces pues habría que ir al lugar en
donde estaba el conocimiento del pueblo
que es la biblioteca municipal y en esos
años también para nuestros amigos
millenials no existía wikipedia existía
una cosa como ésta que da las
enciclopedias en donde uno buscaba la
letra de la palabra que uno quisiera
analizar y entonces buscó la tomo de la
p buscó la palabra pobreza y me doy
cuenta que era un problema sumamente
a las noticias pero de todas las buenas
noticias me doy cuenta que hay una
ciencia social que busca darle respuesta
al problema de la pobreza que se llama
economía entonces decido cambiar mi
trabajo para responder la pregunta de
por qué somos pobres en 'hidalgo'
y si quieren lo vive en un principio
desde un punto de vista egoísta
porque en mi lógica era haber
soy pobre me di cuenta que éramos pobres
y cuando de repente te das cuenta y
pones en la realidad que el dinero de tu
familia no alcanza que tus vecinos y
compañeritos de la escuela te miran feo
porque traes la ropa viejita y bastante
mujercita porque tu familia la
discriminan porque habla la lengua
indígena que es el otomí o niño este y
mientras la gente pues trae su coche
nuevo este trae cosas bonitas y quiere
aprender a hablar inglés tu te das
cuenta que perteneces a otro grupo y te
sientes discriminado entonces en mi
lógica dije a ver
si uno puede entender la pobreza y darle
una respuesta a la pobreza ojalá yo dije
de ser pobre y quizás fue un punto de
vista bastante egoísta pero en ese
momento dije yo quiero responder el
problema de la pobreza porque quiero dar
una solución al mismo y de paso a todos
los demás así que decido estudiar
economía y eso quizás hacer una de las
primeras
diría yo
mensajes que les quiero dar a ustedes en
ese momento me di cuenta de la
importancia del porqué de las cosas
porque cuando tienes una idea del porqué
de las cosas por qué hace las cosas
tienes un motivante detrás te ayuda a
generar un blindaje porque la vida no
estaba fácil y más adelante se genera
una cantidad de problemas que por tener
muy claro qué es lo que quería ayudaron
a salir adelante
claramente en mi trabajo no respondí al
porque éramos pobres
después recibo soy aceptado en el tec de
monterrey campus querétaro y de repente
me doy cuenta de que había un mundo
entero por delante
ese mundo
pues
yo no lo conocía
llegó al tec de monterrey y de repente
me doy cuenta que tenía compañeritos que
hablaban perfecto inglés incluso la
prepa en el tec en ese entonces había
dos grandes grupos del grupo de beat
cultural y el grupo de la prepa normal y
como en las antiguas castas el grupo de
la prepa normal había los que eran ricos
los que eran medio ricos los que eran
pobres y los que éramos bien pobres y
los que éramos bien pobres éramos los
que andamos en transporte público los
que teníamos un par de tenis un par de
zapatos los pantaloncitos y tres
camisetas y entonces me doy cuenta que
no tenía otra cosa más que ponerme a
estudiar la gran suerte que tenía es que
sabía que quería estudiar quería ser
economista entonces me pongo a estudiar
termino la prepa con dos o tres nueves
de todas mis calificaciones que habían
sido diez y entonces me empiezo a ganar
el respeto de mis profesores de mis
compañeros y se empiezan a abrir
oportunidades una de esas oportunidades
es ir a estudiar eeuu eeuu y si no
pregúntenle a cualquier persona que vive
en uno de los pueblos a que diga algo es
sinónimo de
[Música]
éxito y así yo no veía porque mis tíos
iban a trabajar en eeuu y en eeuu
regresaban con un chorro de dinero y una
camioneta como éstas y entonces
me doy cuenta que hay un futuro por
delante termino la prepa me voy a
estudiar al itam y si el té que había
sido una gran experiencia y también un
salto cuántico porque mis compañeros
eran hijos de doctorados hijos de ex
presidentes y la verdad yo compartía
quizás algo en común con los chóferes y
la señora de las quesadillas y si fuera
poco de las cosas que se pueden
complicar pues se me complica en segundo
semestre de repente me dicen por
cuestiones familiares se acabó el dinero
y ponte a trabajar entonces yo dije a
ver la opción que tengo es ponerme a
trabajar pero si me pongo a trabajar voy
a dejar de estudiar y voy a hacer el
perfecto caso de que no se puede salir
de la pobreza a ver yo estoy haciendo
esto para salir de la pobreza no puedo
ser yo el caso de fracaso cuando yo lo
que busco son casos de éxito entonces se
me prendió el coco y dije voy a hacer lo
que millones de mexicanos en este país
hacen voy a tomar las vacaciones que
tengo para irme a trabajar eeuu de qué
limpiando mesas como cocinero etcétera
entonces
aquí tengo una primera lección de vida
conozco uno de los cocineros y uno de
los cocineros me dice papacito ya usted
lo veo que viene muy estudiado pero aquí
no se confíen aquí todos somos iguales
todos tienen que chingar le por igual
porque aquí nadie lo va a venir a
rescatar y entonces se me quedó muy
grabado ese mensaje y ese mensaje tiene
una clave muy importante para acabar con
la pobreza cuando la gente ve que las
oportunidades son justas cuando lo que
tú ganas por tus propios méritos y no
porque eres hijo de amigo de él juniors
de la gente le echa ganas y hace que las
cosas funcionen tiempo después terminó
este tres años de educación y entonces
en ver la oportunidad de trabajar en
banco de méxico y en secretaria de
hacienda y ahí es en donde me doy cuenta
de la enorme diferencia que hay entre
las políticas que se hacen en un
escritorio con un presidente con lo que
vemos en la realidad
y entonces dije
algo me hace falta creo que tengo que
estudiar más si quiero darle una
respuesta a la pobreza no me puedo
quedar con lo que tengo y entonces dije
pos a dónde hay que irse estudiar pues
vámonos a estudiar a la universidad más
importante del mundo a la universidad en
donde está el mayor número de premios
nobel la universidad en donde
seguramente alguno de los premios nobel
en economía me puede decir cómo vamos a
acabar demonios con la pobreza en méxico
y entonces me doy cuenta que tengo una
gran limitante una de ellas el inglés
porque porque el inglés que yo había
aprendido y que había practicado
teniendo como compañerito un
expresidiario trabajando en un que toqué
para y chicken o en un burger king pues
no era suficiente la verdad para estar
en harvard entonces qué es lo que hice
me voy a estudiar al reino unido para
que pudiera ingresar a las mejores
universidades del país cuando tuviera el
nivel académico y así terminó en harvard
y cuando uno dice pues ya está todo
listo
me van a aceptar en harvard no voy a
estudiar la mejor universidad del mundo
pues uno se enfrenta a la realidad de
este país que estamos llenos de
burócratas muy creativos con poco
sentido común y entonces cuando yo llego
a la instancia federal que daba las
becas para esto me dice oiga jovencito
pues que bueno aunque lo aceptaron en
harvard pero fíjese que por sus
compañeritos del itam
se van directo a harvard y andan viendo
el reino unido- yo creo que ustedes la
regó entonces pues pues no olvídenlo no
le vamos a dar una beca y yo les dije
oiga este nada más que ponga las cosas
en contexto mientras mis compañeritos
del itam este y van a primarias
bilingües inglés-español las primarias
bilingües que por cierto también tenemos
en ixmiquilpan son español o tome la
lengua indígena que se hable en mi
pueblo mientras mis compañeritos se iban
todos los veranos a harvard a estudiar
yo me iba también todos los veranos eeuu
pero a trabajar para pagarme la escuela
en otras palabras lo que le quiero decir
es que hay gente que llega allá arriba
por el elevador ya vemos otros que
tenemos que subir las escaleras y subir
por las escaleras te toma un poquito más
de tiempo entonces pues esta funcionaria
muy creativa lo que nos dice es
pues fíjese que es una lástima porque
esta institución está para apoyar a la
ciencia y no para apoyar a los pobres
imagínense lo que sentí imagínense
siento que mis padres habían sido los
primeros en ir a la escuela y eran los
primeros que sabían leer y escribir en
toda la historia familiar que yo había
sido el primero que había tenido
estudios universitarios que había sido
el primero en tener un estudio de
posgrado el primero en graduarme con
honores el primero en estudiar en el
extranjero y el primer unirme a la
universidad más importante del mundo y
que te digan eso afortunadamente toqué
otras puertas abrieron otras opciones
días antes de que se acabara la
oportunidad de irme
harvard logro irme a harvard y me llevo
a harvard la misma pregunta que me llevé
cuando iba en la secundaria que tenemos
que hacer para salir de la pobreza en
hidalgo
25 años después de que me hizo esa
pregunta con diva en la secundaria hoy
tengo el gran honor de haber sido
invitado por el gobernador a trabajar
como secretario de desarrollo económico
en el estado
prácticamente uso en su realidad y
ahorita yo me siento con la obligación
moral de retribuir con la obligación
moral de contribuir para que se generen
oportunidades en el estado y ninguna
hidalguense tenga que apretarse el
cinturón
y a lo largo de todo esto lo que yo
quiero compartir con ustedes
es que en cierta medida lo puede lograr
en el momento que define un por qué en
mi vida
y ese porque me genera un blindaje me
genera una ruta clara metas muy
específicas a seguir
hace unos días
[Música]
estaba en una cena
con un par de amigos
y platicábamos en la coyuntura política
de los malos políticos de los malos
candidatos y la verdad es que esa
plática era sumamente deprimente porque
la conclusión que tenía la mesa es mía
que unirle
y yo les decía
hagamos el siguiente experimento
ustedes se acuerdan cuando estamos en la
primaria
pasabas al frente que te decía la
maestra y te preguntaba por favor
explícanos qué hace tu papá y comentarle
a tus compañeros qué es lo que hace tu
papá y entonces vos tenías compañeritos
que decían luego pues mi papá es médico
este mi papá es policía y otros querían
decir mi papá es bombero ahora
imagínense
que un niño pase y diga mi papel
diputado
mi papá es presidente
imagínense la reacción de los demás
niños
está cañón
como es posible que como sociedad
hayamos llevado una de las funciones más
importantes de todas las sociedades que
es el dirigir el futuro de una comunidad
de un pueblo a una posición tan
desprestigiada
y yo les decía acaso los políticos
tienen una información genética
diferente son de otro planeta o qué es
lo que hace para que actúen de esa
manera
yo en lo personal no creo que los
políticos
ni vengan de otro planeta ni tengan una
información genética diferente lo que
creo es que quizás como sociedad hemos
perdido la capacidad de preguntarnos el
por qué estamos haciendo las cosas y les
ponía el siguiente ejemplo imagínense a
dos médicos uno que decidió estudiar
medicina
porque quería curar a la gente otro que
decidió estudiar medicina porque vio que
era una profesión que pagaba bien
cuál de los dos médicos ustedes creen
que va a tratar mejor a sus pacientes
ahora imagínense esa situación en el
servicio público
en la política
yo creo que es lo que está pasando por
eso uno de los mensajes que quiero dejar
con ustedes es que nos cuestionemos el
por qué hacemos las cosas
hace un momento yo les decía
de que la pobreza es un problema muy
grave en este país en lo que lleva esta
presentación han nacido aproximadamente
70 niños de esos 70 niños 35 nacieron en
la pobreza
de esos 35 que nacieron en la pobreza 17
se van a morir siendo pobres
este es un llamada lección
esta conferencia se llama derribando
muros
como sociedad podemos derribar muros
como sociedad podemos hacer una sociedad
mejor el tiempo que dejemos de echarle
la culpa a la gente es tiempo que
dejemos nada más de imaginarnos cosas
chingón as y nos pongamos a hacer cosas
chingón as que nos pongamos a poner
empeño nuestras tareas pero eso sí
siempre pensando el por qué estamos
haciendo las cosas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]